antes de empezar dejadme haceros una
pregunta conocéis alguna empresa de
andorra mientras os lo pensáis dejadme
que os recuerde que este vídeo ha sido
posible gracias a su usar
luego os doy más detalles pero antes
vamos con nuestra historia de hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]
si estáis en el mapa de españa veréis
que hay un puntito justo en la frontera
con francia este puntito no es un error
de imprenta es un país y se llama
andorra tiene unos 70 o 80 mil
habitantes y desde hace tiempo se ha
puesto de moda en los medios españoles
por noticias como esta
[Música]
anuncia que se mudó andorra y reabre el
debate sobre el pago de impuestos de los
influencers exacto andorra se ha
convertido en el destino de moda de
montones de youtubers principalmente
españoles pero no sólo hablamos de
youtubers desde artistas hasta jugadores
de poker profesional andorra parece
estar a punto de convertirse en una
especie de sillicon valley del
entretenimiento online y diréis pero que
tiene este país que atraiga a tantísima
gente la respuesta es simple impuestos
bajos andorra tiene uno de los tipos de
impuestos más bajos del mundo
en españa todo esto ha generado un
tremendo debate ideológico sobre si está
bien o está mal marcharse otro país para
pagar menos impuestos y aquí en visual
polític no vamos a entrar en ese debate
porque hay una pregunta mucho más
interesante una pregunta que casi nadie
se ha hecho en ningún medio la pregunta
es esta conocéis alguna empresa de
andorra
seguramente no y a lo largo de este
vídeo os vamos a explicar por qué pero
hay que hacer antes un paréntesis en
muchos medios se ha dicho que andorra es
un paraíso fiscal y eso no es cierto
andorra puede tener unos impuestos bajos
pero no forma parte de ninguna lista de
paraísos fiscales al menos no en este
momento recordad esto porque va a ser
muy importante a lo largo de este vídeo
lo que sí podemos decir es que andorra
es uno de esos micro estados europeos
con impuestos muy pero que muy bajos
sin embargo fijaos en esta gráfica
a diferencia de otros micro estados como
el lic de stein o mónaco andorra el nou
es especialmente rico en 2018 tenía una
renta per cápita de 42.000 dólares es
decir que estaba al nivel de francia en
otras palabras que traerá tantos
millonarios andorra no es ni de lejos un
país ultra rico y la pregunta es por qué
por qué no hay grandes empresas en
andorra pese a tener unos impuestos tan
altos
y lo que es más importante de verdad
andorra puede convertirse en todo un
hollywood para los youtubers dicho de
otra forma si eres un youtuber y te
estás planteando mudarte a este país es
una buena o una mala idea hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
antes de hablar de cambios de residencia
fiscal tenemos que hablar de cambios de
residencia virtual cómo podemos evitar
las restricciones geográficas en
internet cómo podemos evitar la censura
de ciertas dictaduras en internet pues
está claro con una vpn y cuál es la vpn
favorita de visual político exacto sur
shark vpn sur shark es una vpn
fantástica y súper segura por ejemplo
nos ha pasado alguna vez que entráis en
una página web y os salen un montón de
ventanitas de publicidad pues eso se
llama físico y por ahí se cuelan
montones de cookies y de virus que se
meten en el móvil o en el ordenador
como ya sabéis todos sus arts tiene una
herramienta que se llama clean web que
bloquea todos estos pop pop si todos
estos enlaces que tienen más peligro que
un saco de bombas
[Música]
pero no sólo eso con una única cuenta de
surf shark podeis registrar todos los
dispositivos que queráis el móvil la
tablet del portátil no hay ningún límite
de dispositivos y como siempre tenemos
una oferta muy especial para todos
vosotros que seguís visual política
básicamente si utilizáis el código
político mirado en acá tendréis un 83%
de descuento más tres meses extra
totalmente gratis es más podéis probar
su usar durante los primeros 30 días sin
ningún compromiso en la descripción
os dejo los enlaces y ahora sí vamos a
ver un poco de historia
el país que quiso imitar a liechtenstein
es imposible hablar de andorra sin
compararlo con liechtenstein
básicamente parecen hermanos gemelos
ambos son micro estados situados entre
grandes montañas y con impuestos bajos
[Música]
liechtenstein tiene unos 30.000
habitantes y andorra más de 70 mil lift
stain está en los alpes y andorra está
en los pirineos ambos países son
principados han mantenido cierto grado
de soberanía durante siglos y se
mantuvieron neutrales durante la segunda
guerra mundial sin embargo la andorra
que conocemos hoy en día nació en 1982
es en ese momento cuando aprobaron la
constitución que tienen hoy en día y
cortaron todos los lazos de dependencia
que tenían con francia y ahora pensadlo
por un momento qué haces cuando tienes
un país pequeño aislado entre montañas y
sin grandes industrias como puede
prosperar un país así
[Música]
[Aplausos]
andorra decidió imitar el modelo de
light stage y así es como se
convirtieron en todo un paraíso fiscal
con impuestos bajos iba abajo o
inexistente y sobre todo secreto
bancario es decir que los bancos
andorranos no estaban obligados a
compartir información de sus clientes
con los estados
con esta estrategia andorra quería
convertirse en todo un centro financiero
global un suiza o liechtenstein de los
pirineos el problema el problema es que
nunca lo lograron
durante décadas andorra fue un lugar
perfecto para esquiar comprar
radiocasetes baratos y blanquear
capitales además al ser considerados
como paraíso fiscal por casi todos los
países europeos tenían un montón de
restricciones para hacer negocios el
caso de liechtenstein es muy distinto
mientras la única gran industria de
andorra era el turismo ict stein había
desarrollado su propia industria y sus
propias empresas sin embargo todo cambió
en el año 2016
[Música]
el final del secreto bancario de andorra
tease para las regularizaciones de nuevo
al igual que hizo light este año una
década antes
andorra acabó con el secreto bancario
eso explica que desde el año 2018
andorra saliera de la lista de paraísos
fiscales de la unión europea y ya sé lo
qué pensaréis muchos esto sería el fin
de la banca andorrana toda una crisis
para un país tan pequeño verdad pues
nada de eso a partir de 2018 andorra
entró en la lista de posibles destinos
para muchas grandes fortunas sobre todo
las de aquellos que tenían y tienen
negocios online porque pues ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver
hollywood de los youtubers imaginad que
tenéis un pequeño negocio en internet
podéis trabajar en cualquier parte del
mundo donde vivir y aix en un país como
españa donde podéis llegar a pagar más
de un 45% de impuesto de la renta o en
andorra donde sólo pagas un bien
hablamos además de un microestado que
está a 200 km de barcelona e incluso hay
una ruta de helicóptero barcelona
andorra aunque el idioma oficial es el
catalán se puede hacer la vida en
castellano sin ningún problema y diréis
pero de verdad es tan fácil mudarse
andorra pues lo cierto es que si
básicamente sólo hace falta pagar 15 mil
euros a la hacienda andorrana en forma
de fianza y ser el dueño de al menos el
21 por ciento de una empresa local si no
encontrás una empresa puedes crearla tú
mismo el capital social son tres mil
euros lo mismo que en españa la
diferencia está en los impuestos en
españa el tipo máximo de impuestos de
sociedades está en el 25 por ciento
mientras que en andorra está en el 10%
así que es lo que hace mucha gente pues
se quede una empresa y se pone un sueldo
de 40 mil euros al año los primeros 24
mil están libres de tributar y los otros
16 mil euros tributan a un 5% el resto
del dinero se cobra en forma de
dividendos de empresa que están libres
de impuestos y sólo pagan un 10% por el
impuesto de sociedades como veis parece
un movimiento perfecto
y diréis pero como es posible que un
estado se financia con impuestos tan
bajos en principio debería ser posible
el 58 por ciento de los contribuyentes
son extranjeros muchos de los cuales
tienen rentas altas y digo debería ser
posible porque en realidad andorra tiene
unos agujeros en sus cuentas públicas
importantes pero de eso vamos a hablar
más adelante porque ahora vamos a
contestar a otra pregunta de verdad es
tan fácil de verdad la tienda española
no puede hacer nada para perseguir a los
ricos que emigran andorra y lo cierto es
que no básicamente si vives en andorra
más de 183 días y tu principal centro de
interés económico está fuera de españa-
el estado no puede hacer nada contra ti
y diréis pero un momento si un youtuber
tiene un canal en español sus ingresos
vendrán de españa' verdad la respuesta
es que no y lo mismo pasa con la
audiencia en realidad con la ley actual
sólo hay una forma de perseguir a
alguien que tributa en andorra y es
demostrar que no vive o que no trabaja
ahí por ejemplo si un youtuber andorrano
montar una empresa en españa y todos los
ingresos dominan día
entonces sí que podría tener un problema
de hecho existen ejemplos de artistas
que fingían vivir en andorra y que
finalmente han caído en las garras de la
hacienda española atentos
[Música]
shakira afrontará una causa penal por
defraudar 14 5 millones hacienda y os
preguntaréis pero porque alguien iba a
querer montar una empresa fuera de
andorra se supone que andorra es el
lugar idóneo para hacer negocios y aquí
es donde viene lo que nadie os ha
contado de este país veréis cuando
empezamos la investigación para este
vídeo pensábamos que andorra podría
convertirse en todo un hollywood para
youtubers sin embargo a medida que
buscábamos información nos llamó la
atención una cosa puede que andorra
tenga la mayor concentración de
youtubers famosos per cápita de todo el
planeta tierra sin embargo no tienen ni
grandes estudios de grabación
networks ni ningún tipo de empresa
auxiliar y diréis por qué pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
porque andorrano es liechtenstein una
cosa es cierta
andorra sabe como nadie atraer grandes
fortunas pero volvemos a la primera
pregunta del vídeo conocéis alguna
empresa andorrana por ejemplo irlanda
también es un país famoso por tener
bajos impuestos eso explica en parte
porque las grandes tecnológicas eligen
este país para establecer sus sedes
europeas google facebook o apple tienen
oficinas enormes en irlanda pero no sólo
hablamos de empresas extranjeras ryanair
o prime marks son compañías
internacionales nacidas en irlanda y
algo parecido pasa con liechtenstein
podéis recorrer' liechtenstein de norte
a sur en sólo 15 minutos de coche y
durante todo el viaje sólo veréis
fábricas y oficinas una detrás de otra
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
venga ya hombre liechtenstein pero si no
conozco a ninguna empresa de
liechtenstein pues os equivocáis o son
una empresa llamada hilti son el líder
mundial en herramientas y maquinaria de
construcción es más seguro que muchos de
vosotros tendréis una taladradora de
marca hilti en vuestra caja de
herramientas y me da igual donde viváis
si os vais a cualquier obra de
construcción seguramente encontrareis
estructuras diseñadas por esta empresa
tienen presencia en todo el mundo pero
su fábrica más importante y su centro de
i + d está en sant que es un pueblecito
de 6000 habitantes situado en el
principado de liechtenstein pero no sólo
eso la próxima vez que vayáis al
dentista fijaos en las máquinas que
tenéis alrededor seguro que muchas
tendrán el logotipo de ivo claro viva de
esta empresa es la líder mundial en
prótesis y maquinaria para dentistas y
de nuevo su principal fábrica está
también en sant leaf está
sin embargo cuál diríais que es la
empresa tecnológica más importante de
andorra
andorra telecom la empresa que se dedica
a proveer de telefonía e internet a los
ciudadanos andorranos
cuidado silicon valley que llegando
rápido fuerte en todos los listados de
empresas andorranas que hemos encontrado
solo hay sociedades unipersonales
empresas que ni siquiera tienen página
web si mis queridos amigos de visual
política tener impuestos bajos no es
sinónimo de tener un sistema económico
competitivo y andorra es el ejemplo
perfecto y diréis pero qué problema
tienen en andorra porque no han
conseguido crear grandes empresas la
primera razón es el terreno en un país
tan pequeño y tan montañoso
es difícil encontrar terreno para
construir oficinas fijaos en esta
noticia del año 2020
nueva promoción de lujo en el centro de
escaldes engordany en un impresionante
rascacielos es impresionante rascacielos
tiene 20 plantas y es el primer edificio
alto que se construye en andorra y
fijaos bien porque se trata de un
edificio residencial es decir que no es
un edificio de oficinas y diréis pero
qué problema tiene andorra para que
nadie quiera montar empresas por aquí
pues atentos
del paraíso fiscal al infierno
empresarial imaginad que sois ese gran
youtuber y vivís en andorra hasta aquí
no hay problema el problema viene si
queréis crecer vamos a suponer que
tenéis vuestra sociedad creada pero
ahora queréis dar un paso más y
convertirla en una productora una
productora mediana con guionistas
editores y animadores pues bien en el
primer año sólo podéis contratar a dos
personas así tal cual como lo oís pero
esperad porque esto no es lo peor la
legislación laboral andorrana es más
nacionalista que el peluquín de donald
trump y su premisa es los andorranos
primero
eso significa que por ley estaréis
obligados a priorizar a los andorranos
por encima de cualquier otra persona
para atraerse a alguien de fuera hay que
pasar por todo un infierno burocrático y
eso explica porque fuera de las grandes
fortunas andorra es incapaz de atraer
talento
por seguir con la comparación
liechtenstein se ha convertido en todo
un hub de industria médica y de alta
precisión si seis ingenieros podéis
intentar buscar trabajo por aquí cada
día miles de personas que viven en
austria y en suiza- cruzan la frontera
para trabajar en los polígonos
industriales de este país sin embargo
andorra solo atrae a profesores de esquí
y camareros
[Música]
pero esperad un momento porque este no
es el único problema recordáis que os
dije que andorra no ha sido capaz de
crear grandes bancos pues eso también es
un problema desde que acabaron con el
secreto bancario los bancos andorranos
pasan más controles burocráticos que los
de cualquier otro lugar
suiza tiene varios de los bancos más
grandes del mundo y liechtenstein tiene
el banco el gt que es propiedad de su
familia real para que os hagáis una idea
standard and poor's le da un rating de
a- plus y está considerado como uno de
los bancos privados con mejor reputación
del mundo que tenemos en andorra su
banco más importante es el banco según
la agencia de calificación fitch tiene
una calificación de bbb y no la ve no es
precisamente de bueno
pero espera porque todavía no hemos
terminado sigamos con el ejemplo del
youtube
somos un creador online y queremos hacer
crecer nuestro negocio venga vale no
podemos traer talento fuera tenemos
problemas para conseguir financiación
pero no pasa nada podemos asociarnos con
una empresa de e-commerce y lanzar
nuestra propia marca de merchandising
puede que os sorprenda pero esta es la
principal vía de ingresos de muchos
canales sin ir más lejos sal y bale en
alemania o jeffrey estar en eeuu han
montado auténticos emporios gracias a
vender sus propios productos a través de
sus canales
[Música]
ah
el problema el problema es que andorra
no forma parte ni de la unión europea ni
siquiera del mercado común mientras lic
de stein es el puente que une suiza con
la unión europea
andorra no es un lugar competitivo para
tener un almacén y diréis entonces cómo
es posible que andorra atraiga a tantos
dueños de e-commerce pues por esto
[Música]
dropshipping en andorra un modelo de
negocio muy rentable la mayor parte de
los ecommerce de andorra utilizan el
método dropshipping y diréis skins el
dropshipping pues en lugar de tener
nuestro propio almacén usamos parte de
otros
por ejemplo supongamos que montamos una
tienda de zapatos yo gestiono la tienda
online desde andorra cuando el cliente
español hace una compra el almacén que
vamos a poner que está en china manda
los zapatos al cliente es decir que yo
ni siquiera llegó a tocar el paquete
esta opción es fantástica para ecommerce
que están empezando pero tiene datos
grandes problemas márgenes muy bajos y
tiempos de entrega eternos efectivamente
muchas empresas del sector han empezado
utilizando esta técnica pero en cuanto
adquieren un volumen terminan usando sus
propios almacenes y aquí es donde la
situación aduanera de andorra es de todo
menos competitiva pese a tener los
impuestos bajos
[Música]
en otras palabras que si andorra quiere
convertirse en un silicon valley del
e-commerce un hollywood de youtube o un
las vegas del poker online más vale que
haga reformas reformas serias y
probablemente impopulares
y ya sé lo que estará pensando algunos y
para qué querrían tener empresas a fin
de cuentas tal y como están parece que
viven bastante bien y si tenéis razón
los millonarios son andorra lo mismo que
el petróleo de son los países del golfo
su principal fuente de ingresos el
problema el problema es que no puedes
depender de la llegada de profesionales
de renta alta además si no hay razones
empresariales para retenerlos es
probable que muchos se marchen más aún
si tenemos en cuenta que andorra no
cuenta con políticas de integración más
bien todo lo contrario por cierto que
esta es otra diferencia con
liechtenstein en otras palabras que si
dentro de unos años todos o parte de
estos profesionales de alta retribución
se marcharán dejarían un agujero en la
recaudación de proporciones jordi anas
ésta nos la veía venir verdad y por
extraño que suene en andorra sabe muy
bien lo que significa tener definidos
el presupuesto de andorra para 2019
presenta el déficit más bajo de la
última década esta noticia es del año
2019 un año después de que actor la
dejara de ser declarado punto arise o
fiscal es decir un año después de que
comenzara esa oleada de youtubers
jugadores de poker y pequeños
empresarios pues bien incluso en ese
ejercicio
andorra cerró con un déficit de sólo un
2,7 por ciento pero es que para este año
2021 estiman que van a cerrar con un
déficit del 16 por ciento y diréis pero
como pueden tener problemas de déficit
en un país lleno de millonarios pues
básicamente porque ingresan poco y
gastan más de lo que deben en que pues
por ejemplo en cosas como esta
e
el aeropuerto d'andorra las podría tener
varias compañías operando el próximo
invierno habéis oído bien pese a tener
78 mil habitantes
andorra comparte un aeropuerto con
españa de nuevo esta es otra diferencia
con liechtenstein
aunque el leaf stain tenga una renta per
cápita cuatro veces más alta que la de
andorra no tiene un aeropuerto porque no
lo necesita pues bien en el momento en
el que hacemos este vídeo este
aeropuerto no tiene ningún vuelo
comercial y cuesta la friolera de
trescientos mil euros al año a los
andorranos puede parecer poco dinero
pero recordad que toda la recaudación de
andorra en 2021 va a ser de 397 millones
de euros
e
así que señores del gobierno de andorra
si estáis viendo este vídeo creo que
tenéis tareas pendientes si queréis más
información en la descripción os dejo la
entrevista que le hicimos al príncipe de
liechtenstein el señor hans adam segundo
está en inglés pero seguro que os dará
alguna idea antes de terminar me
gustaría darle las gracias a andorra
services a vicente rojo y a samuel
rodríguez de commerce news por habernos
ayudado con la investigación para este
vídeo mientras tanto ahora la pregunta
es para vosotros queréis que andorra va
a hacer las reformas necesarias para
convertirse en un hollywood youtuber o
existen lugares mucho mejores para vivir
cuál os parece el mejor lugar para vivir
y montar empresas podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis y aquí en visual
politics sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribiros al canal y
darle a la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones si
os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like y
nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto